5 4 3 2 1 une 30
avec au soutien le chef qui crâne vert
mon dieu il y a France Maroc oui tout le
monde redoute que tout soit cassé sur
les champs ah je suis inquiète oui oui
parce que ils vont tout casser car la
communauté franco-marocaine est bien sûr
partagée comme ici à Bordeaux je suis né
au Maroc
le meilleur qu'elle gagne cette
propriétaire a pris une décision
radicale je vends parce que j'en ai
tellement assez les gilets jaunes ils
ont cassé une porte il y a toujours des
trucs vous l'avez lu le journal Le Monde
hier il y a cinq pages sur France Maroc
il y a quatre pages et demi sur le Maroc
et la une c'est des supporters marocains
alors après on en pense qu'on en veut
France Maroc vous voyez la une du monde
c'est les supporters marocains
le débat est lancé mais rien ne me
dérange jamais
c'est beaucoup trop démesuré c'est
démesuré dans quel autre pays sur la
planète une demi-finale de Coupe du
Monde
on ouvrirait en parlant davantage des
supporters adverses que des supporters
de son pays pour moi ça fait sens ça
fait sens dans ce rapport
quand certains et notamment quelques
intellectuels et le monde en fait partie
avec notre beau pays la France on s'est
repéré avec ça ça c'est sûr que les Tour
Eiffel c'est originales quand même de la
France là Tour Eiffel et ça marche à
chaque match de l'équipe de France les
Tour Eiffel sont bien visibles ce soir
elles porteront peut-être chanceux bleu
question intéressante réponse encore
plus intéressante regardez 80% des
Français disent non
19% seulement disent oui il y a
notamment Stéphane Ravier sénateur de
Marseille qui demandait l'interdiction
des drapeaux marins à Marseille
[Applaudissements]
il ne s'agit pas d'une première me
concernant puisque j'avais déjà demandé
ce que les drapeaux les drapeaux
algériens soient interdits lors de la
lors de la canne la Coupe d'Afrique des
nations quand je considère que cela
participe à créer des troubles à l'ordre
public mais il y a aucune raison que le
football
l'image était pas bonne maillot du Maroc
et le drapeau français
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais comment nous vivons des temps
difficiles pourquoi pendant la Coupe du
Monde c'est pas facile pour nous de vous
aimez pas non mais de comprendre de nous
voilà en général c'est pas toujours
facile de comprendre mais il y a
beaucoup de femmes dans les stades et de
la télévision
vous comprenez la règle du jeu non c'est
fou ça oui les femmes ont besoin de plus
d'heures de conduite pour avoir leur
permis 31 heures en moyenne contre 27
heures seulement pour les hommes oui
mais voilà une fois qu'elles ont leur
permis elles ont beaucoup moins
d'accidents que les garçons puisque
presque les trois quarts des jeunes
conducteurs masculins peuvent être
considérés comme de mauvais conducteurs
alors que ces deux fois moins comme
proportion chez les jeunes femmes je
suis parisienne donc ça peut être dans
les embouteillages ou en regardant un JT
du monde agité que que j'ai quand
j'étais dans des zones de stress j'avais
un peu le juron facile donc Gilles
delatourette c'est un syndrome attention
rien à voir avec cette maladie ou soit
on jure ce qu'on a des tiques etc
nerveux alors c'est
j'ai vraiment je suis très respectueuse
avec les gens qui ont vraiment cette
maladie mais j'ai un petit syndrome
voilà poissonnière dans les
embouteillages
[Musique]
c'est quoi le le juron le gros mot là
alors que j'ai pas mis là-dedans il y en
a que j'aime bien parce qu'il est en
même temps méchant et en même temps très
imagé c'est plutôt borgne bande de
méchants pollueurs avec votre fromage
fondu et votre charcuterie vous polluez
selon les calculs de nos confrères le
bilan carbone d'une raclette et le
double de celui d'une tartiflette et
même 8 fois plus qu'une ratatouille le
plat signature d'un Pauline en cause en
cause le fromage et la viande qui pèse
lourd dans le bilan carbone alors le
site vous propose des alternatives pour
une raclette et correspondables
attention accrochez-vous à l'époque
Vincent Van Gogh se déplace en train à
vapeur très polluant voilà ce que l'on
peut lire dans un musée situé à
Saint-Dizier c'est un internaute
spécialiste de l'arc qui a pris en photo
cette annotation il y a aussi cette
autre légende sous une gravure du 16e
siècle une injonction à réduire notre
consommation de papier pour protéger nos
arbres dans les commentaires des
internautes créés à l'anachronisme et
dénonce des jugements stupides
hallucinant de bêtises elle a après le
visuel de chacun son tour et elle a fait
une robe et des boucles d'oreilles
regardez il y a même les boucles
d'oreilles remplacer la viande par des
champignons ou des brocolis voir de
l'ananas
des brocolis qui nous dit on se marie
très bien avec le fromage fondu vous
pouvez aussi faire des économies
d'énergie il vaut mieux baisser le
chauffage avant de lancer l'appareil à
raclette plutôt couvrir les fenêtres à
la fin quand la pièce est beaucoup trop
chauffée et Jérôme c'est le paradis des
animaux dans tous en cuisine c'est
vraiment ça
on aime tout le monde nous ici tu sais
bien le paradis des animaux convaincuser
ce soir d'ailleurs on les salue au
passage